All right, welcome back to the gun bench. Today, this is going to be episode two.
We're going to build
the Smith & Wesson SD-9.
That's another pretty inexpensive, widely available
kit that you can either get from every gun part or gunbroker.
Today, I have a frame here printed in the translucent blue.
I think it's like Sunloo.
Years ago, we would have never used a translucent filament, but the filament science has come a
really long way since then, and this stuff comes in red and blue and clear, I think, and maybe even
another color or two, and it's pretty stout. So I've been super impressed with it.
You know, it's not for everybody, but it holds up really well. Not quite like carbon-fiber nylon.
This isn't the type of frame that you can leave in your glove box
during the summer, but you know, it is flashy and it's fine for range use or
having a nightstand. So anyways,
so yeah, we're going to build this gun, so let's get started.
Yeah, so this is just a piece of music wire, put the printed catch in,
take the music wire and slide it down into its place.
Really needs to go just a little bit lower. There we go. Let's see if we can get that to go in. All right, good deal.
All right, so in order to
to build one of these SD guns, you're going to need this. This is a
SD rail.
That Riptide rails sells. So the rear rail is actually built into the rear
sear assembly. And so
you order this from Riptide,
it goes in the front pocket of this frame right here, and it installs with a three millimeter
pin that comes with it.
If you have trouble getting these in, one thing I learned is you can take these pins. You can turn them
on a file.
Just on the end to give it a slight chamfer and
that helps it find its way.
Most of the time, they'll have a little bit of a fillet on there, but it's,
you know, it's pretty tame.
All right, then we're gonna put
this rear sear block in. Let's go ahead and put this rear pin in.
The sear pin is the one that looks like a roll pin. It's hollow in the middle.
As opposed to the trigger pin that's solid.
Yeah, I'm gonna have to drive that one a little bit. I noticed earlier that this was just a wee bit tight.
You have to be careful, but it never hurts to actually have a hard hammer
with some of these.
Heh. I'm gonna have to pull off camera for a second. I'm still working out the, working out the camera details.
So you get this roll pin installed.
Now it's time for the trigger group and the locking block.
So
you'll want to make note of a couple things.
Yeah, Smith and Wesson, it's really funny. They've held on to this
archaic trigger spring design right here.
What you'll do is when you put this in, you're gonna have to get the trigger pin not only through the,
you know, slide catch and the locking block, but you'll also have to get it through that ring.
If you're not really careful with that and you, you know, you kind of hand-fisted in there,
you can destroy that ring and you'll have to go buy another spring.
So, you know, it's good to at least watch what you're doing in that regard.
This little hook just kind of goes around this
back part here like that.
We're gonna drop in this and then we will take this
slide lock
and we're gonna, we'll basically slide it in next to the trigger underneath the locking block.
Now, usually what I like to do is I'll try to get a punch in there and
get it all kind of lined up.
It's especially critical with that ring.
Yeah, that's
So I have a, and this might, this might actually work.
It's just a piece of a music wire. What I'm trying to do
is I want to try to align that ring so that I can stab through the middle of it, almost.
There we go. All right now, that's lined up and not great.
So what I'm gonna do, we're gonna start this trigger pin.
It doesn't make a huge difference, but technically that
slot should go on the slide release side. It's meant to catch that
spring and you can usually push this. I don't know if you can see that, but the ring of the spring is
around my trigger pin.
Probably can't see it because this focus isn't great, but that's really what you're looking for.
And then you can, oh, I didn't get it through my slide lock.
That's all right.
A little bit more. Yeah, there we go.
All right now, I think that's got it.
Yeah, so that's a little bit tricky. The the wire spring is pushing this slide lock down,
so it's misaligned in that hole. So you need to, you know, there's a couple of ways to do this,
but if you get it where it's dragging on the end of that pin a little bit on the opposite side, you can
like what I did with that punch is you can lever it up. It kind of hangs
there enough for you to
push the pin forward.
Last step will be, before we install the slide,
is the...
Haha. It's gonna be the spring.
Oh yeah, here we go.
So this, okay, the spring that comes with this is a
one of those like flat leaf springs.
This uses, you know, basically like the, I don't know, what is it, a Gen 5
coil spring.
This is a really mangled example of one
because it's just what I had laying around.
And it was working, but it's pretty deformed and it's, you know, it works, but it's not great.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna kind of push that down into the
recess and then we're gonna slide this in over the spring.
There is a lip here on this takedown lever that faces
back towards the back of the gun. If this is facing the wrong way,
your barrel's not gonna lock
when the slide shuts. It's gonna want, it'll try to bump over this. So
what we do is we kind of start it over the top of the spring there and
you take a small screwdriver and kind of push it down just to get it, get the shoulder of it started. There we go. And then
yeah, get it into place.
And once we do that, we can put this on
just as a commentary. These are convertible to run on
these are close enough that you can convert these to run on Glock Lowers.
I have a guide out to do that and we'll do that one day.
And there you go.
That's a
Glock Mag SD9. Those kits, you know, they're usually around a hundred bucks, maybe a little less.
Not as cheap as the SR guns, but you know, if you keep your eyes open, you can catch a deal.
And
you know, they're good guns.
Anyways,
I hope you enjoyed this. We'll see you next time.